le répit fut de courte durée après une
accalmie de quelques mois les
automobilistes devront possiblement
payer plus cher leur plein d'essence
comme du yoyo
se stabilisent la prochaine voiture
c'est sûr que ce serait électrique c'est
vraiment décourageant la voiture c'est
nos pieds ce n'est plus le luxe on a
besoin de ça pour travailler cette
nouvelle eau s'explique notamment par la
décision de l'oper plus l'Organisation
des pays exportateurs de pétrole de
diminuer sa production de pétrole de 2
millions de barils par jour au bout de
la ligne ça va chauffer définitivement
au prix à la pompe donc plus là 55% de
l'offre mondial c'est énorme et cette
décision n'est pas anodine selon cette
expert des questions énergétiques il
s'agit d'une réponse directe aux
sanctions imposées contre le pétrole
russe cette approche inscrit dans un
contexte géopolitique très complexe on
rentre dans une période critique
actuellement dans le secteur énergétique
il y a vraiment une guerre énergétique
semaine entre la Russie et l'Europe et
également les États-Unis et ce sont les
consommateurs qui en paieront le prix
mais difficile de prédire à quel point
exactement
d'éventuelles fluctuations des prix
dépendent de plusieurs facteurs à titre
d'exemple si l'Europe connaît univers
difficile l'essence pourrait coûter plus
cher il y a d'autres variables aussi qui
jouent est-ce que la chaîne va se
déconfiner sur la Chine se déconfine
évidemment va consommer davantage de
pétrole et de gaz ça va compliquer un
petit peu la situation pour les
Européens en contrepartie une éventuelle
récession pourrait ralentir cette hausse
des prix c'est une crise sans précédent
avoir des conséquences très importantes
et qui pourrait à terme forcer les pays
riches à accélérer leur transition
énergétique affirmive enclich car qui
dit véhicule électrique dites aussi fin
de la dépendance au pétrole ici qui me
permettra au Canada Montréal